[Music]
thank you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
epic hello I'm Charlie Hudson and I'm
thrilled to welcome you to the Age of
Empire's 25th anniversary live
celebration today is all about age we're
talking it's history it's Evolution its
future obviously most importantly it's
incredible fans around the world that
have made this game rightly so a global
phenomenon and so we're going to be
doing this with you we have so much aged
goodness to show you like exclusive
trailers and announcements but we want
you to be part of the show as well head
to this link here twitch.tv forward
slash XBox where we'll be having polls
competitions giveaways and a look at
some brand new gameplay
speaking of which I'm in your way you do
what you need to do it's not just me
that she posting the show though also
with me here today our community host
wellin who is going to be keeping this
party going Round the Clock if you do
have any questions though he's your guy
hey everyone my name is wellin I'm a
gamer and a streamer and a lifetime Age
of Empires Enthusiast and today I'm live
with all of you from Xbox Studio on the
west coast but I have a question for all
of you chat where are you guys from
I deeply want to know because this is
something that is there he is indeed it
all by Glory
oh we are sliding back Kenny Hall
gamer indeed
it is actually me why are you surprised
about this
yet the Netherlands okay Canada Atlanta
can't more Canadians Argentina D.C
Brazil Wales the dragon Mexico all right
this see this is what's so great AOE is
so Global I just love it all right well
we have more stuff for you let's talk
about giveaways see in partnership with
Alienware we are excited to share our
grand prize giveaway of an exclusive
custom r13 gaming PC so in twitch chat
use keyword exclamation point age up
your setup to win and do this right now
do not type claim I know how that's a
little a little Goblin meme don't do
that all right and now the giveaway is
only available to our North American
viewers but there will be more prizes
for everyone internationally throughout
the show so for those International
Gamers to win put in keyword exclamation
point age 25. and also stick around
until the end of the show when I will be
hosting some very epic aoe4 and AOE 2
Gameplay I'll see all of you in a little
bit and keep the comments and questions
coming I'll get to as many as I can
throughout the entire show
thank you Ellen isn't it lovely now
folks make sure you stick around until
the end of the show because there is an
amazing Live musical performance that I
promise you it's unlike anything you
have ever seen before
now there have been a lot of rumors
swirling out there about this next
announcement and the thing about rumors
is sometimes they are indeed true so
this is a direct message to you Robo
htid you asked me this on Friday and I
think it's about time I answered it for
you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ERS see what I like about this
announcement is that all of you right
before stream were like please we want
console and and I saw it like three
different languages too so you guys now
have console but I want to hear what you
think about this see I'm curious about
how you're going to control all the
units because I personally I'm mostly a
PC Gamer but I'm curious do you are
there hardcore console gamers in chat
I'm not talking about casual console
gamers
this is series finally on Console indeed
indeed
this is true
CrossFit I'm not sure about that I'm
very curious to see that what I'm what I
think I might do is a little challenge
is you could play on your uh Xbox your
PC and so many ways to play you know
I love game big business
casuals can go home no we welcome the
casuals in the community this is a
friendly Community everyone is welcome
what is a hardcore console gamer see you
console Gamers this is what I'm trying
to this is what I'm trying to say this
is this is slander towards you guys
Cronus like the Titan indeed my birthday
too favorite strategy all right well you
are slowly okay thanks gamer
um and chat you may have noticed we
dropped a poll we're gonna do something
we've never done before it is time to
get all of you in chat involved all
right Charlie let's show them
cheers well and I'm going to give you an
amazing look at this unbelievable Age of
Empires 2 table we've got right here so
we're going to have a little cheeky tour
first up we've got the Aztecs chilling
over here with their Mills and their
town center right down by the lake
looking lovely no idea what's going on
and over here chilling in the mountains
are the Japanese approaching with their
archers but we want to know what you
want to do here so you saw the poll in
chat get your votes in I'm gonna step
away now because I don't want to get hit
though I do have theories on what I want
to see you do well in you got this
you know it's excellent question because
I often bring 300 IQ tactics High ELO
gameplay so what I would do is I'd
consult twitch chat so what's the move
chat that's the thing I have this hive
mind of a hundred people individually
who knows but together you're Geniuses
only good answers here get your votes in
and um
all right so do we have a winner are
there who who why must we fight have
them talk it out this is this is an
anachronistic battle
we have the Japanese and the Aztecs in a
great a war for the ages
do we have a winner
okay all right the Aztecs are the
winners Steve let's cue up the video of
the Aztecs attacking
and there it is they're attacking this
ancient Pagoda
this is this is pure Devastation folks
there they shot one scorpion bolt and
set it Ablaze perhaps it was Greek fire
that was embedded within that scorpion
bolt we even have a cinematic angle of
an instant replay
okay but now there's a counter attack
these are crenellations being destroyed
folks they one shot those all right well
that was that was that was pure Warfare
we just witnessed what a battle Charlie
what's up next
[Music]
absolutely amazing I think you and Chad
up there absolutely smashed the right
decision but don't worry Age of Empires
3 fans because stay tuned you are up
next but first let's gather around the
campfire and take a lovely trip to
Memory Lane
in rare moments throughout history
a movement grows so strong so powerful
that it becomes Legend a legend that
spans decades continents that spreads
across our world this Legend involves an
army of sorts Millions strong from
children to the age from the hardcore to
the Casual Warrior no one is turned away
to succeed in this Army you need not be
strong with armed but strong of mind and
heart I speak of course of the legend of
Age of Empires
foreign
this Legend begins at the dawn of
civilization
1997. even in the dreaded age of dial-up
internet a spark of creation grew in
Dallas Texas and heralded the rise of
greatness
a sophisticated real-time strategy game
set an authentic historical ages players
chose a campaign and turned a handful of
villagers into a thriving Empire
progressing from primitive Stone Age
through the tool bronze and iron ages
players could conquer the ancient world
from the Mediterranean to Egypt see the
famous Hanging Gardens of Babylon and
Rule alongside Hammurabi or dominate the
islands of Japan under the light of the
Rising Sun players weren't just choosing
different scenery each civilization had
distinct unit advantages and
disadvantages Age of Empires was
expanded by The Rise of Rome which
introduced technological innovations
like unit Cubit and hotkeys the
expansion grew not just the world of the
game but the fans of Age of Empires into
a force that was Millions strong the
game was so popular that later on it was
given out for free and cereal boxes in
Australia just a year later Age of
Empires 2 The Age of Kings was released
in an entirely new time period And
across different Landscapes players
could conquer fresh Horizons they could
invade Eurasia with Genghis Khan Crusade
with Barbarossa
drive back the Invaders with Saladin
Inspire their country with Joan of Arc
or protect their homelands with William
Wallace the discovery of hidden cheat
codes helped ease the path to Victory
some of these cheat codes gave military
units crucial help on the battlefield or
fed hungry villagers while some
[Music]
gave you
gave you a car while some things had
changed others remained the same players
had to be careful yet bold patient but
also Swift if they used their resources
wisely players could make technological
advances in the military economy
religion and if no you'll never convert
me be gone via priests after Conquering
the world of man those behind Age of
Empires set their sights on New Horizons
now players could travel to mythological
Realms interacting with creatures of
lore as the Atlantean war hero arcantos
they traveled across known and unknown
worlds from Atlantis to Egypt to the
Northlands ever since its release
players have longed for a definitive
edition of Age of Mythology but it has
remained the stuff of
myth
Age of Empires 2 introduced another
Innovative function multiplayer accounts
players could face off with real enemies
across the world or across the room
Age of Empires 3 picked up in the late
16th century with players exploring
North America in a quest for the
fountain of youth players could choose
between eight different civilizations as
they followed the story of the black
family through five ages the campaign
opened up the possibility of other
civilizations and the expansion packs
added in more options with the WarChiefs
and the Asian Dynasties Age of Empires 3
also introduced the Havoc physics engine
and home cities cheat codes of course
remained highly sought after
unfortunately the AI evolved along with
the game okay you king of the losers
with these four first games Age of
Empires had established itself across
the world the popularity of the game
grew and spread Age of Empires 2 and 3
were re-released on Steam but it wasn't
enough fans needed more more Empires
more worlds to conquer
so when Microsoft told people to ask me
anything online fans jumped in and asked
could we please have more Age of Empires
Microsoft replied how many empires do
you need
in 2017 the torch was passed to a new
band of innovators these new explorers
scoured the corners of the earth
bringing forth an accuracy and detail
never seen before we took what was
already pretty incredible and just made
it even better
finally in 2018 the first Definitive
Edition was released the original Age of
Empires had been given graphical
improvements 4K resolution and a
remastered soundtrack it was everything
the players had loved about the original
game now using the most modern
technology The Definitive Edition
started with looking at something that
was already going on a small group of
passionate guys at the age two Community
were working on this unofficial
expansion fridge of Empires 2.
on the 20-year anniversary of the
release of Age of Kings a definitive
edition of that game was released it
featured new Ai and 4K resolution that
allowed players to see their unfinished
castles in Crystal Clear detail it also
introduced in-game colorblind options
expanding accessibility
Innovation that continued with the
definitive edition of Age of Empires 3.
along with other upgrades this Edition
would grow to include more civilizations
including Africa Mexico and the
Mediterranean all the while players
continued to harness their power testing
their strategies in tournaments across
the world a fight song sounded the Beats
of war
and heroes emerged the Viper taking home
his first Red Bull champion
and in 2021 a new chapter in the legend
was released with Age of Empires 4.
building their Empires from the Dark Age
through the Imperial age with stunning
Graphics vast Landscapes and new ways to
taunt their opponents
but the story isn't over yet as long as
players across the world build new
empires outmaneuver their enemies and
protect their people Age of Empires not
only continues to grow it evolves
inspires transcends it becomes greater
than the sum of its parts it becomes
Legend
now that was truly an epic history what
did you guys think of that documentary
because it's been 25 years folks I I
have another question is there anyone in
chat younger than Age of Empires because
the thing is like I played this game as
a kid and so I'm I'm slightly older than
Age of Empire so I don't know if that
makes me a boomer compared to you Zoomer
Gamers but
um yeah
um
but yeah no it was pretty epic yeah fat
fantastic vid oh I am 21. me what is
this
nice Boomer kick W come on don't boomer
me gamer
bro is probably 24. I am younger than
AOE okay and now is it who is the oldest
person in chat that's the thing not only
is when earlier we were looking at
everywhere that people are from today I
feel like young people and older people
enjoy this game it's not like you need
to be young with your Fortnight fingers
or something everyone has uh has has a
different appreciation and a different
style of playing the game I am 50
someone said they're 130 but I doubt it
because then you'd be the oldest person
I think the oldest person was 126.
ah but
um we also have another very cool uh AOE
3 tabletop coming right up Charlie can
we get to the uh a03 okie dokie we're
back with Age of Empires 3 and Wellen
chat the poll is already up and I want
to know who do you want to attack let's
have a look now we've got the United
States in their town on this side
looking lovely and comfortable but over
here whoa we've got Malta approaching
from the coast with their warships I
want to see these votes coming all the
way through as we check out the table in
its full Glory but I'm going to step
back once again so you guys can see all
the action well then over to you in the
safety of your studio cool
all right chat well we've got us versus
Malta you can see this idyllic
picturesque Village of the United States
off the coast in The Frigid waste of the
north and what do you think we have the
Maltese battleships off the coast let us
know in the poll because this is an epic
battle that is about to unfold we need
to know folks the cannon galleons are
poised to attack we have the the
defenses set up of the United States on
the Eastern Seaboard all right what are
we voting malta's ship cannons the votes
are in folks we have a winner Steve
let's cue up the video of that attack
ah the okay I was correct those are
Canon galleons right and they just one
shot that house it did not stand a
chance that was a that was a village
hall and a house that both got one shot
destroyed but there's a counter attack
there was a counter attack there
shooting flames they are not they're not
taking this sitting down the American
revolutionaries rise up once again but
folks we've got another tabletop coming
right up at you with more Age of Empires
4 and we're dropping another poll in
chat right now we've got a different
sort of genre a different time period
they a different uh style of battle that
will be occurring we've got
um I believe the malians and the
Ottomans
I believe uh here we go yes all right
what are we gonna do here folks
all right Charlie let's take a look at
the table top
chance again an amazing choice in fact I
was telling well and earlier that if it
was up to me that's what I would have
done though I certainly would have
turtled significantly harder but now
we're going to check out our next two
newest Civilizations for Age of Empires
4 the Ottomans and the malians I'm going
to give you some fun facts about them as
well as we look here so the Ottomans
have a powerful Siege Weaponry like
these great bombards you can see getting
ready to go and mess some stuff up and
over here we have the malians who are
suited to swiftly outmaneuver their
opponents I hope you're taking notes but
as I said as you can see they are going
head-to-head to battle it out once and
for all so get your votes in as we take
a closer look at all the amazing detail
on this table I am once again running
swiftly away to dodge any straight
arrows and it's over to you Ellen a wise
move all right folks keep voting see
this is a classic Battle of Swift and
sneaky speed versus Power brains Brawn
alright it looks like the Malian Scout
with the Sheep has won Steve let's queue
up the video
I am prepared to see battle here folks
it will initiate at any moment the
destruction beginning now but but
Ton Man
the chronistic hero that
shooting a laser cannon actually it
makes sense that he shot with a laser
cannon that it got set on fire there's
even a replay this is good stuff that
building is being devastated by this
large laser being shot
but but the ottomans are this is a
vicious counter attack they not they
didn't one shot if they two shot it in
all fairness
um but that Photon man was somewhat
unexpected yeah I did not anticipate
seeing him there all right well Charlie
what do you think of that battle
delicious wonderful shop boat on man I
knew he wouldn't let me down in the old
destruction department for 25 years
though you have played on a slightly
bigger PC than this I'm guessing who
would have believed that you can have
age in the palm of your hand is that
correct I guess so watch this
[Music]
[Music]
well well we saw it ask we saw it ask
there were multiple things that were
being asked and now you can play on your
little smartphone device and also if you
think about it you there are a lot of
ways to play this game now you know
we've you could even go on your console
mobile and computer see I asked if there
are hardcore console Gamers earlier are
there any hardcore mobile Gamers this is
something that I don't know about
entirely because there may be Gamers who
are entirely devoted to being just
absolutely cracked out of their minds on
a little mobile device
foreign
why are you saying LOL we are we are
laughing giggling we are joyful
No Such Thing damn these these these
mobile Gamers don't take this slander
towards you guys well we have more to
give away use keyword exclamation point
age 25 and twitch and enter to win an
AOE Mouse look at this bad boy look at
the the fine detailing the craftsmanship
hmm yes very impressive and it's just an
early taste the big prizes are yet to
come remember to follow twitch for the
grand prize PC rig okay and now
I've seen this in chat I'm just saying
we have an announcement okay shrouded in
secrecy and myth this one Harkens back
to an earlier time and I'm very excited
to share it with you Steve roll that
video
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I saw everybody saying like oh we want
this where is aom and I was like I I was
I was just
they don't know they don't know so we
have an Age of Mythology retold this is
this is can we get can we get a
prostagma in chat
this is so epic this is so epic I just I
everyone is gonna remember a hero has
fallen that's gonna be seared into your
memory I still hear that in my
nightmares sometimes
and hey yeah all you guys earlier were
like oh they're gonna do this you know
they're gonna do that but now they've
really done it gosh darn it we've got
some prostagmas in chat
this is big business all right well
folks that is a big time announcement I
saw some Emperors and fellow Emperors in
chat but let's give away some more
prizes look at this amazing AOE beer
stein Gamers please drink responsibly
use keyword age exclamation point age 25
to enter to win these Steins Charlie
what did you think about that
announcement hey chat I guess it's not
the stuff of myth anymore is it I am
sorry I couldn't help it but the fun
doesn't stop there I promise you it is
the 25th anniversary after all so I've
heard we have to go pretty big check
this next one out
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
mate you took the words right out of my
mouth but I'm gonna have a chat with
chat about it all right okay so let's
recap new civilizations new settings and
I think you'll agree the graphics are
chef's kiss absolutely amazing but I do
hear you out there you want another one
don't you well here you go coming up
fresh
welcome to a new season of Age of
Empires 4 complete with brand new
civilizations Somalians and Ottomans
join us in celebrating the Monumental
25th anniversary of Age of Empires in
season 3 anniversary
right Seasons evolve you've shown off
your solo combat abilities in 1v1 ranked
games
now you'll be able to team up with a
friend and compete for top titles
together in team ranked for the very
first time what's a new season without
fresh rewards earn them through team
ranked matches solo ranked or as part of
the 25th anniversary seasonal event
challenges and by gaining Mastery with
the new Ottoman and Malian civilizations
then in December the first ever mini
events ton of toys which includes a free
Monument
anniversary celebrations bring new
content and Old Friends
sound the alarm as Photon man makes his
debut appearance bringing with him the
much anticipated cheat system to age
four
who can now demand more food please with
the new taunt system and
your enemy with a
you can also unlock all new taunts
throughout the season are you ready to
battle
the party doesn't end there we've got
eight new maps joining for this Birthday
Bash including Mediterranean and Oasis
based on classic maps from Age of
Empires one and two the season 3 update
includes highly anticipated Naval
gameplay improvements deeper economic
management increased combat volatility
more intense RPS counters and more
additional improvements have also been
made to late game AI resource Gathering
choke point and Scout improvements as
well as a number of General balance and
quality of life changes
[Music]
that's just a glimpse of the exciting
things coming in this season 3
anniversary celebration
we look forward to celebrating the first
anniversary of Age of Empires 4
alongside 25 wonderful years of age of
Empires with each and every one of you
don't forget to bring the party balloons
and streamers
or chat wellin it's fantastic to finally
have you here with me in the Great Hall
do you like what I've done with the
place isn't it great I love it very
Majestic and impressive
picked up on that I think you could kind
of say the same about the stream so far
though right what's it been like up
there with chat sort of teasing everyone
to give away this Beast as well well
I've been enjoying the cheeky banter I
know lots of stuff and I'm really
excited about Age of Mythology retold oh
I think chat were particularly excited
you got them for me I was definitely the
most excited I mean aged completely took
me off guard when that came along but um
and the Age of Empires do come into
console Twitter we finally have
something we could talk about this is
fantastic news
um but yeah back to this giveaway who's
won it is it mean I could have it if you
want me to well we've got a winner okay
great but this Majestic machine custom
Age of Empires Alienware PC we have a
winner and our winner
AKA underscore oh good congratulations
to you not only have you won that but
I've got one more piece of news to give
you I shall take the floor now so for
any Age of Empires fans out there we've
got one more bit of news we will be
bringing Age of Empire's Definitive
Edition into the Age of Empires 2 d e
engine and we are going to have more
information to share on this in 2023 I
do however don't I don't have anything
to add about this I don't know what's
going on that's a chunky fella he is
chunky enough that I do not understand
how they use the stairs I shall
investigate later on yeah but we are not
done no no you all are gonna love this
performance by the idol villagers and in
about 20 minutes I will see all of you
upstairs for some very epic games and I
don't think it could come in a better
time I don't know if you've just noticed
we are under siege should we get out of
here yeah he's gonna be there chat enjoy
the show we'll see you in a bit
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
how do you turn this on
[Music]
how are the bells of Norwich and other
people come and know here by the tower
Julian I tell them what I know
all shall be well again I know
[Music]
on the yellow daffodil is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
waiting for the yellow daffodils are
louder in the snow ring for the yellow
got a little down yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I standing at me
[Music]
far away from my friends
[Music]
[Applause]
shoulders
[Music]
shoulders
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jack in your wallet that's me on your
dollar bill check in your pockets the
quarters me too
sovereign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yourself with me
[Music]
so bring yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bring us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
to the ships with the sails like wings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and London
[Music]
[Music]
drink to the glory field where a man
Embrace his death
thank the gods that we live at all with
our joyous dying breath
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
trebuchet more like trevorier
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
father's father wore it and your father
wore it too
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
gone away
[Music]
alone tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
what happened to the Spanish
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and that Winter's gone away
start the song already
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hahaha
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
elephants on the boat but we can't fit
11 archers
because elephants have extra trunk space
wait what
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my goodness that was phenomenal a
massive thanks to the idol villagers for
what just might actually be the best
music performance of all time but I'd
also like to thank you well and you've
been amazing at helping me host the show
today and chat you've been spot on as
well but there is a little bit more we
have lined up for you isn't there indeed
we have some very epic gameplay coming
up alongside some juicy giveaways and uh
yeah so we'll see everyone in a few
minutes absolutely yeah give us a couple
of minutes to freshen up we'll meet you
upstairs and continue to fun thanks so
much for joining everyone bye bye
is that your camel you know he's not but
I think he's sat next to me on the
flight here you know it's cute
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]